What is your opinion on taking zeolite?
So zeolite is a binder slash key later.
So I don't have any trouble taking zeolite.
The only thing you have to be careful with with any of the key
later. So a key later is something that will is a new nutrient that grabs
on to chemicals and heavy metals.
Oh, well, I want to take that.
Well, you've got to go back and you guys all have access to my seven phases of detoxification
course. Highly recommend that you go through it or at least skim through it.
Because that will tell you that, you know, you have to make sure all the phases of your
detoxification pathways are open before you do chelation, which is in my book phase zero,
which is the last thing you would do.
Well, I'm doing all these other things.
I've already done all I do detox all the time of good coffee animals.
Okay, that's great. Then maybe it is time for the key later.
But there's several things that you really have to know.
You don't want to take any strong key laders.
If you have heavy metals in your mouth, like mercury fillings.
So if you have mercury fillings, you never want to take strong key layers.
So if you still have mercury fillings in your mouth, silver fillings,
then you can never take strong key layers.
Because you will just pull it out of your mouth and put it into your body.
That will not be a good thing.
Second thing is, is if you have a metal implants.
So if you have metal implants in your body, you should never be on strong key layers.
Well, what's a strong key later? So strong key layers would be the EDTA.
And DMSDSMO.
The MSO.
The MSA, that's what it's called.
Those would be the strong key later. So that would be it are.
Our key la clear, which is our phase six.
I would not take that product.
Can you take zero light, zero light would fall into a medium key later, medium strength key later in my book.
You can probably get by taking zero light with metal fillings or mercury fillings or dental implants or metal implants.
But, you know, just don't overdose on it.